okay I'm gonna start timer because this
is the first time I've given this talk
and this is the first time showing this
demo so I have no clue how long it
should take hopefully we're gonna keep
it on their own like 30 minutes because
there's quite a lot of stuff to set up
and set down
hello everyone my name is Zach Akhil I
am here and this is the first time we're
doing this and it's not rehearsed how is
everyone doing everyone ok cool so you
just had lunch so you're probably all
that all the blood flows go into
digestion your food not so much to the
brain I hear that science so this is
going to be a nice chilled out hence the
clothing talk I'm not gonna go into like
crazy depth hopefully I think well I
can't judge myself but I've seen I've
seen a few of the other talks today or a
few snippets of them and they all they
all were like really really useful this
is more in contrast to those I want to
first sort of set this set the stage of
what this is kind of gonna be like so
first of all I will wait for this to
turn on and then and then what perfect
great start let's click exit restart
there we go what's my jam so I like
building stuff that's sort of more
physical and I sort of I got my start in
programming with Arduino and Raspberry
Pi is how many people have used Arduino
Zoar raspberry PI's quite a few yes so
it's like really fun physical stuff so
this is an example of the kind of stuff
we build where I took like a
scikit-learn model and I would export or
it all the weights whilst it's training
and I visualize them on like a 3d
printed RGB LED strip so you can
physically see the training happening so
this is an indication of something
that's really cool and isn't actually
that useful so like I cat like it was
literally so it's you can probably sort
of see oh you can see here that's
actually on my apartment wall that's
it's a piece of
it's not a useful thing well that's
that's that's controversial to say but
okay that's an example other stuff like
to do is like things with the real world
so vision application so machine vision
is anyone here done any machine vision
any machine vision engineering machinery
okay so this is an example of one where
I've done analysis on a basketball shot
by building like custom tensor field
models one of my recent ones and this is
this is a really good example this is
some of you might have seen it this is
an example of a robot that would give
you feedback about the food that you eat
and the way that it gave you feedback
was more physical so the idea is that I
built this just before New Year's so
it's like a new year's resolution robot
and so yeah it's using Raspberry Pi it's
using a cloud hosted machine learning
and then yeah you don't need to think
about the food you just come back set it
on your desk and if it's still there you
can eat it that's oh that's see
hopefully everyone's kind of lower their
expectations for how useful this top
might be which is a great way to start
okay I never bite enough about me what
about you okay so who's in the room who
here has actually built the machine
learning model before hopefully mostly
people care awesome cool I've got a list
here who here has used a Raspberry Pi
okay noted who here has used GPU
acceleration for a faster training quite
a few people who here has used GPU
acceleration for faster training okay
and who here has heard or use TF light
models oh damn
okay there's good things to focus on all
right awesome
so who here cycles cool
so who here cycles in London oh it's a
different it's a different crowd and who
here would recommend cycling and London
to a loved one oh damn oh that's that's
heartless okay so yeah if you've ever
cycled in London it's it's known to be
quite perilous
you've got to watch out for a lot of
things you gotta watch out for buses
trucks motorcycles and other cyclists
this is anyone recognize where this is a
couple of people so yeah this is a this
is the place in near Farrington so on my
commute I used to cycle up through here
and there's a interesting psychopathic
comes through here and what would happen
is there'll be two sort of channels of
cyclists fit on this path and there's
this like turnoff so you get the inside
channel cyclists will come up and then
go to turn left and then the outside
will continue on straight now there are
no markings to indicate this so if you
haven't cycled this route before you're
not going to know that if you are on
this side of the cycle path that the
site is turning out that line is gonna
stop quite abruptly because there's
traffic lights there but the line next
to you is going to keep going and this
happened to me and I was I was in the
lane that was gonna be turning off but I
wanted to keep going straight and so
naturally okay this this line was
slowing down but the line next me there
was no one there so I just turned out
into it I quickly realized based off of
some aggressive yelling from a cyclist
behind me that I didn't look behind me
and he was actually right right right
there however I couldn't have looked
because I was looking forward so there
was this thing where if I just knew what
was behind me it would be useful and
there's many other instances where this
sort of thing would help like one time I
try to pull on a motorcyclist was
overtake me at the same time which is
which is happens a lot and then also
cycling home on like a more quiet Road
not realizing that cars coming up behind
you quite quickly maybe because you're
listening to like the sound of birds
definitely not your headphones so this
is a problem I want to try to solve it
and I want to first yet by the way if
you're cycling London you might need
superhuman abilities looking backwards
and looking forwards is equally as
important how do other people solve it
or how does it already been solve my
bikes well there's this technology
that's quite useful known as mirrors so
some people use these mirrors I don't
like them because they look a bit ugly
but also I've come up with a reason why
they're not good and that's because
you actually have to look at the mirror
to use it so you have to look down which
is quite a big way to look so from there
to there and then you have to like run
your own classification model as to
what's behind you so yeah so I don't
like that and also like it doesn't run
machine learning so that's I don't like
that but these also exist who's never
seen these so you can actually get
rearview cameras for bikes I know yeah I
didn't know that existed but it's the
same as the mirror so I don't like it
okay so what do other modes of transport
use well handy people at Tesla they've
got their a self-driving car that
doesn't actually self-driving but we
won't talk about that it can use a
mirror of sensors to detect all the cars
that surround it and if you've ever been
in one of these things you get this cool
little UI readout of like what's next to
your left or to your right and this
image doesn't show it but what it also
does is I put an arrow to remind me to
say this it will actually do kind of
classification as to what's around you
so if you've got a truck it will display
a truck I think I may be remembering it
through roasting the glasses but I think
it does actually do that it displays
different sizes of vehicles you can
anyone confirm this no okay well look
assume it's true yeah okay cool
all right so yeah that's that's a cool
idea of class finals behind you because
if you're cycling in London different
vehicles you probably should react to
them in different ways so for example
the bus although it looks quite
intimidating it's actually I find it
personally not that bad to cycle around
and I think that's due to all the
visibility that the bus driver has up
around the vehicle like all the windows
they don't even got cameras mounted
everywhere so I think they're actually
relatively safe to [ __ ] around on the
other hand you've got these sort of
vehicles which the same size as buses
but with next to no visibility and being
able to classify what the different
types of vehicles are behind you will be
useful so we could say like this is a
nice gentle giant and you've got
apocalypse machines just coming out
behind you so I want to build a system
that Kenna does this so the idea the
plan is imagine I've got an image that's
been taken from behind my bike and I run
a classification ball along it so
specifically
an object detection model who here is
familiar with object detection models
hopefully most people yeah so object
detection model is a model that can take
in an image tell you what's inside the
image and also where specifically inside
the image it is so if I could do this
this would be cool but then I need to
relay that information to me
I was thinking of audio like through
headphones but I don't wanna do that I
want to do vision so the idea is putting
lights on the handlebar it's like an LED
bar and so if there's something
dangerous on your right-hand side light
up bread if there's something not so
dangerous light up green yeah so that's
the plan so how am I gonna build it so
I've previously built some stuff and I
want to I want to use a Raspberry Pi
because it runs Python that's it and the
Python in the Raspberry Pi comes with a
camera module that works really well
with it so I'll use that as well for the
output I'm gonna use one of these so
who's heard of an LED strip like most
people yes so you see them in like so
these sort of cheap shops as lighting up
stuff but those you power them and they
just run a single color this is a
special type of LED strip called an
addressable LED strip and that means
with code we can actually send
individual commands to individual LEDs
to tell them to turn it on and off so
that's gonna be perfect for the project
specifically it's a neopixel leds strip
now this isn't important now but it is
important later but we'll get on to that
all right for the model there's loads of
object detection models out there so I'm
thinking why bother build my own so I'm
gonna use this one mobile that single
shot detector version one because it was
the first one I found online the data
set used to Train it it's gonna be the
cocoa dataset who's heard of the cocoa
dataset so I just recently heard of it I
didn't actually check what dataset was
used to train the model but this is the
one that was used to train the model
it's a big open envision data set that
has vision labels for segmentation
object detection and classification and
probably more what's really cool about
it is that built into it you can want to
find out more you can go to this this
URL about that data set but built into
it it already has labels for cars buses
trucks bicycles and motorbikes like
perfect I don't have to label my own
data set I can just use this and what's
even better is I can find a pre trained
model online so I'm just going to use
that now ty for the demo
hopefully I'm good for time yep ten
minutes in
right so I like I like doing demos for
talks usually they're not as stressful
as the demo I'm about to do because
usually there are software demos
Hardware demos are a different story so
what I've got here is some special
hardware that is going to run on a
bicycle and if you look towards the back
of the room you will witness a diversion
because it's actually down here and
all right
so what I've done I built bike because
it was easier to build one than just you
know find one on the street so go bike
right whoo all right but it doesn't
stand by itself ha ha built a stand all
right just like that see I'm having to
actually build the demo but look no
handlebars boom so handlebar slide on do
this it's like an Ikea demonstration all
right so the handlebars are on I think
that's it Oh power
no it's powered ok I switch to the
Raspberry Pi
I've lost the keyboard here it is I wake
up the right there it is oh yes and you
can see the really good resolution I
have to guess the last command I ran
okay so we've got here we've got the
Raspberry Pi mounted on this side it's
not invisible Raspberry Pi let's just on
the other side we have the LED strip I
need to connect the LED strip so let's
remember the colors this one yes
and power the LED strip you ready I'm
not okay there's light now what I'm
gonna do I've built my model I've it's a
model that's compiled 2tf light it's
designed to run fast on mobile I have
here the latest Raspberry Pi does anyone
know what the latest raspberry pi is for
Oh everyone cool
I see yeah this is the Raspberry Pi 4
and I'm gonna run the model let's see
yes that's what it that's what it sees
maybe oh yeah you can't see the light
okay this is gonna be injured so
everyone can see everyone nice because
everyone needs to see the handlebars
okay Wow well approach that later so
there's no cars in this room yet all
right so this is an this was a very
strange expense report to fill out so
we've got buses we've got um oh there's
a nice grey car there all right but
there's no roads got Road look at this
all right got a road but it's a bit too
low down and I there we go I built
something really cool a piece of
cardboard just to get it a bit closer
all right so what we can see here is the
model and the model speed at the top
this is how long the mall takes is to
actually make the prediction it's taken
about three hundred four four hundred
milliseconds let's see if it's actually
gonna work because it wasn't trained on
toy cars all right it's naturally it's
gonna be not good because why would it
be it's a large mo okay it's kinda going
it's lighting up the handlebars anyone
in this room okay you can relate to that
side but the handlebars are lining up
red on this hat maybe you can see off my
hand yeah okay so it's working
but look a friendly bus
I'm the head of our lights of green on
this side kind of okay so the world
machine our engineers the mobile isn't
trained on toys I'm neither with with
all you puts from this camera so that
works all right for my first attempt
okay so key points to make is the speed
of the top three around 400 milliseconds
so this is the first model all right I
saw it built it it's already built
that's great what more is there to know
well a lot because I there's my timer
halfway through it perfect because I
have a need a need for low latency so I
want to run this maula quite a bit
faster because it's a bit too slow if
the model is only updating my handlebars
maybe once or twice a second on London
roads that's I'm practically dead
already
so what I want to do is get them all to
run faster and I put in a link to this
top description about a talk I actually
gave at PI data a couple years ago where
I was building a same sort of vision
based Raspberry Pi robot for rugby and
the way I made it run faster is I did
this sort of standard approach I need to
make the model less complex but if I
want to reduce the complexity of my
model like make it a smaller model use
fewer layers I probably need to do more
manual feature engineering to compensate
for that so that's why it so this is
actually a gift that I used in that talk
so this is the original input image it's
already trimmed I calculated I call it a
delta image so subtracting one frame
from the next to just get the change in
pixels and then because I was only
interested in panning the camera side to
side I just summed all the pixels along
the vertical axis so it reduced the the
input feature space massively and it
made the model run quite a bit quicker
so it went down from like second or two
down to still only about like 300 400
milliseconds it was a cycle our model
and so that was that was a good cool
approach but I still had to do the
feature engineering and I for this
application I kind of have no clue what
kind of feature hearing to do that would
help reduces come play
model so another option is to increase
the hardware speed so to use GPUs so
GPUs there are graphical processing
units they're designed and engineered
for graphics most of graphics is just
matrix multiplication and handily enough
so is most of deep learning so there is
that shift where we started using
graphics cards to do faster deep
learning as a demo has anyone ever seen
GPU acceleration before who here has
actually seen GPU acceleration before I
hoping okay a small chunk so let me
actually show people what it is well
first of all this is going to disconnect
which is great so I've got here a deep
learning model for the eminence dataset
so the handwritten digits data set and
this is training on a CPU so it's a bit
small but I'll zoom in okay so we got a
training here it's training the first
epoch and the first epoch is going to
take roughly to two minutes and 30
seconds okay so that's on the CPU now
the exact same code after I reconnect
but this is time it's gonna be running
with a GPU and we will see it goes down
from two minutes and 30 seconds once it
start over there it is oh it's already
almost finished so one what a park it
lasts about nine seconds so GPU
acceleration just has incredible effects
because it's most of deep deep deep
neural networks benefit hugely from
paralyze execution and it's a parallel
is not the word parallel parallel
execution and that's what GPUs are
really really good at so naturally if
you want to try to sell yourself and
you're using your mirror with collab you
can set the runtime environment
somewhere somewhere it doesn't matter so
yeah that's that's power of GPU
acceleration it's very cool so let's
let's take a step back and look at
neural networks 101 point zero zero zero
zero so this is we can agree what a
neural network kind of looks like so
good for time and we train when we train
a neural network we'd get our feature
weights or our weights with inside the
neural network so this is an example of
each connection between a node has a
weight assigned to it and it's learned
this isn't perfect because I'm missing
the bias note if people are being
specific and at each node we're doing
some kind of summation of the previous
nodes connections and bubbled up we
could all agree that's what neural
network does yeah cool except it doesn't
because the numbers tend to look like
this uh-huh
so with standard like Charis Charis is
default way of storing values is in
float 32-bit so this is this kind of
roughly translates to about seven or
eight digits of precision so this is
what I know that returns to look like
which is fine
so let's assume this is an earlier for
predicting car or boat the predictions
will go through but the outputs we tend
to especially for a classification we're
not really doing any precise
calculations we tend to just be doing
something like this so for for just like
single single label classification we're
just saying what's the maximum of this
like but actually let me zoom in so
these I'd puts the boat is 0.98
something something something and in the
car is zero point five nine Sundays or
something well we're getting a
prediction where it's like okay it's
give me the max and that's that's cool
we didn't we didn't need any of the
precision beforehand but that's fine for
things like multi classification we tend
to just be using some quite round
threshold cut off of like whereas it's
0.5 so any any of these that are greater
than 0.5 just give me those back and
even in the case of regression I know
personally a lot of the time I'm not
really using any any more precision than
maybe 2 or 3 decimal places so for
prediction I'm not really don't really
need the precision but the precision is
incredibly useful because only with that
precision can you do things like
gradient calculations accurately which
is incredibly important for our back
propagation to actually work so these
are incredibly important for training
but not incredibly important for
prediction and in case you're wondering
what a boat car looks like that's a book
car so what can we do to make our model
run faster is we can actually just get
these numbers and reduce them so we can
do thing called quantization which is
basically like just writing the numbers
down to a smaller a smaller data type so
our numbers actually start being
represented like this and our outputs
don't actually change that
you can't see slight slight changes but
in terms of because we're doing ours are
still like big round output calculations
we're almost definitely gonna get the
same outputs for meat when we do this
and we end up reducing the size of the
model massively so yeah that's
quantization that's one thing we can do
to improve the neural networks and this
is a change we do in software so this is
like a software optimization this is
great this works great so even on even
on GPUs GPUs will run a lot faster with
quantized models and in fact that's what
TF light models are a lot of time they
they do quantization for you built-in so
they'll run a bit faster because of that
and they'll take up less space in memory
but okay is there any any like computer
architect engineers in the room okay
good because what I'm about to say is
probably wrong so on a GPU when you
store a quantized bit it's probably
wasting some part of the actual chip
because the GPU itself is designed for
32-bit floating-point at least that's
what I find on the internet so the GPU
is actually designed on the hardware
level to do 32 bit float operations so
when we quantize our our data to be like
the smaller bit let maybe 8-bit or
16-bit it is still taking up less space
it will still have to do less
calculations but as we go through the
calculation this is all on use it
probably isn't
keep checking everything else but
there's still that physical space on the
board that isn't utilized so let's
imagine a hypothetical Hardware that is
specifically designed for these
quantized numbers so on the physical
space we might be representing numbers
like that so there's no wasted space all
the numbers and all the operations can
be super close together on the board and
we don't need to imagine anymore we can
have an edge TPU because that is exactly
what an HTP you is so here's an example
of one we have called the dev board I
actually have it here so this is the dev
board so it's like the size of a
Raspberry Pi it is not a Raspberry Pi
I'm going to point out it later so it's
not Raspberry Pi but it has this TPU
Hardware on it so it's a hardware
specifically designed to run these
quantized machinery models and we also
have a USB version which is the
potentially the one I'm going to use
yeah so again this is the the hardware
that is optimized for the quantized
models don't thing I was gonna make
another
yeah they're designed to run fast
because there's taking up less room on
the board they they run the same models
a lot more efficiently and yeah they're
designed to run all the models
independent of like cloud connections so
the models on the actual edge GPU so the
the diagram I showed earlier about how
much space they're taking up on the
board that was kind of an educated guess
based off of this requirement that is on
the website so it says the TP only
supports tensorflow light models that
are fully 8-bit quantized and then
compiled specifically for the HTTP you
so this this is a limitation of the
border can only run these tensor four
light models that are compulsory for it
I because the model I used was already a
pre trained model I didn't have to train
my own model so there's more there's a
specific set list of operations that are
supported the TP seems to be used in a
lot of these cases do with vision so all
this sort of convolutional layer
operators are all supported and I've got
a link that actually lists all the
supported operators if you want to do
learning as I stated before learning
requires this precision to run back
propagation so you cannot do back
propagation on the edge TPU itself
however there is support for some forms
of transfer learning using things like
nearest neighbors and using the actual
neural network to do stuff I didn't do
it so I don't know a lot about it but
here's a link tells you a bit more about
it and if you want to build your model
from scratch this person made an
incredible notebook which takes a Karass
model you build it from scratch in a
collab and it runs through all the steps
to compile it for the edge TPU so that's
an incredible resource so mad props to
Oh Tom and yeah that's the HTTP you
models potholes in my journey before as
I'm strolling before doing this so yeah
as I pointed out before this is not a
Raspberry Pi which I did not know when I
first bought it I assumed that the GPIO
pins if you've ever used a Raspberry Pi
you've got these line of pins that you
can connect anything to so it's roughly
on this side of the board these light
line of pins you can connect LEDs to the
you can connect LED strips other LED
related things and it looks like it's a
Raspberry Pi I thought surely it's the
same and it does run Linux but it isn't
because it turns out this specific LED
strip is a neopixel leds ship and the
library that the manufacturers wrote for
it was written specifically for the
Raspberry Pi and specifically the
hardware architecture on the Raspberry
Pi so for this specific component this
neopixel leds ship I could not get this
to work with the dev board because it is
a slightly different hardware
architecture to the Raspberry Pi that
was the first roadblock and how I fixed
that was I stopped using it the other
roadblock is the Raspberry Pi 4 is a
very new piece of technology and so is
the accelerator only all the
edge-to-edge CPUs are still quite new
and I would not wish on my worst enemy
the feeling of searching on Stack
Overflow for questions that don't exist
like that feeling you could not feel
more alone in the world when you search
and there's just nothing on Sakai but no
one's in kindness and I was always
thinking is like who are the people that
are tackling these problems really early
and then I was good dammit now it's me
but so that was a problem so the default
version of Python on the Raspberry Pi 4
is bronze pipe in 3.7 which is nice go
then but the Raspberry Pi 3s default was
3.5 and that three Python 3.5 is what a
lot of the instructions for the HTTP you
are built around so that's the thing to
watch out for
also the PI camera doesn't like to be
resized I'll just skip that bit final
demo so where is this edge CPU oh wait
it's in my pocket
so here it is alright I'll switch back
so I've got the HTTP you i've got USB
cable and you might notice I've got a
little bottle cage look at that
right and I'm gonna plug this in let's
see this is so on it's still there
Cooper cool I'll plug this in here and
I'm gonna run now who who remembers the
speed of the previous model place three
hundred four hundred gonna run this
model it's gonna be the same exact model
doing the same exact predictions which
are probably gonna be bad but it's the
same model and it's gone from three four
hundred down to forty or less okay let's
see if we can get some nice friendly bus
oh wait go put the road on we got
friendly bus a bit quicker you can see
it moving across the handlebars a bit
nicer I know look dangerous car and the
cars red but let's see that's it's much
much much nicer experience to skip ooh
let's get a red car and out of the red
car so it's much quicker spot and then
oh look the bus comes in between we've
got green red green red maybe you can't
see on that side but it works it's a lot
quicker
but wait there's more because because
it's very quick but I think we could be
quicker and the specific reason why I
made my life a lot harder by using the
Raspberry Pi for as it was released it's
because the Raspberry Pi for has
something special on does anyone know
what has are the special what was that
no but it's good it has USB 3 this is
currently plugged in the USB to USB 2
bottlenecks the accelerate the
accelerator because getting getting the
data on and getting there on is the main
is the main issue with it so I've just
plugged it out of USB 2 I'm plugged in
the USB 3 the speeds in remember what
speed was it was 50 40 all right let's
just by changing it's not the right
script Kerry I'm just guessing
alright just by changing the port from
the USB to USB 3 on the rounds before I
should say more numbers it's gone from
40 to 50 down to bat number all right
and we can see how you got the cards put
it on a friendly bus and they couldn't
yeah don't don't worry about the model
being terrible we really like the the
speed because I could pop I could put in
any model I wanted and the future the
future is of course I'm going to train
an actual model on toys I'm gonna
overfit the hell out of it so that it
works alright so that is that as a
future plan for for the project but yeah
1450 milliseconds on a device the size
of a Raspberry Pi running a full
convolutional model magic but yeah
that's that that's that demo
all right so the final sort of thoughts
is if you want to go out and do sort of
play around with this stuff yourself I
recommend the Raspberry Pi 4 even though
it gave me a lot of help but
specifically the USB 3 gives you such
huge increase and there's probably going
to be maybe I shouldn't pre answer the
question but in terms of the speed
difference between the dev board and the
Raspberry Pi or the accelerator there is
none it's the exact same chip the only
time to get a speed difference is when
the accelerator is bottlenecked by USB 2
so yeah that's one question wasted the
PI camera module there's loads of sorts
an example code that works with the
camera module and the Raspberry Pi so
that's why I think that's the the most
streamlined way of building stuff for it
I would recommend the USB accelerator
over the dev board just because it means
I get to stay in the Raspberry Pi
ecosystem where there's loads of help
online and yeah provided you're using it
with Roz PI 4 you get no reduce
reduction in speed with that thank you
so much to you all for being here thank
you so much for this to work yeah here's
all the code and I'm happy to answer any
questions you have
[Applause]
hey great toolbar though thank you thank
you for that and I just want to ask for
the accelerator do you have to like
install anything or dosages is it just
plug and play oh yeah okay that's a
great question
yeah there is there is an installation
for it and in fact that's another good
reason to use the accelerator USB stick
over this the installation to get this
thing sort of setup is I thought I find
a bit long for the accelerator it's a
pip install it's like - two lines of
installation and you get the code and
loads of example code and stuff yeah is
it the case that whatever like version
attends phone like you've got there is
it just automatically detecting the
accelerator or were you running a
different it's great yes so the the
actual TF light models they have to be
specially compiled for the edge TPU it
takes there's a that that notebook that
I showed is incredible cuz it shows you
the process of compiling it for it but
yeah it goes from a standard TF light
model and turns it into this edge TPU T
apply more which are identical and what
predictions they make but they're just I
guess the code is specific to how the
hardware works but yeah it's a specific
model type how about the battery how
long can you cycle with raspberry Pi TPU
and the camera the battery okay that's
that's a good question I haven't cycled
this bike
so that's a future bit is I haven't
actually mounted this on a real bike
however the TP is supposed to be quite
efficient however I think it gets quiet
it's a bit toasty so I don't know how
efficient it really is but it is being
powered solely by the USB port on a
Raspberry Pi so that gives you some
indication of how efficient it actually
is especially when you do like the
people have done those two benchmarks
online comparing this against desktop
GPUs and this the fact that this single
USB stick outperforms them is sort of a
testament to how efficient it is
actually running the models thanks for
the demo especially I like your demo kit
first question where do you get this
demo where do you carry all you make it
yourself for oh yeah I made this myself
this is all like laser-cut yeah I was
going to initially hand cut it all but
then someone said you can use a laser
cutter yeah and I noticed when you put
the euro dong you're they the accuracy
of the recognise the class and the boss
has been increased and you we thought
that you know your Road seems they can't
recognize anything can you explain that
so that's a good question so I would I
think that it gives the impression that
the accuracy has increased but what it's
actually doing is because I'm able to
sort of move it around a bit more a
little bit more fidelity when it's
making the predictions faster so I was
able to position the car a bit quicker
because it was giving me that feedback
with the original TL final it was so
slow what I did is I moved it around a
bit and then just got bored and start
moving it I'm pretty sure if you if I
move this car around in a in the same
exact pattern it will detect on average
it'll make the same predictions and it
will make the same wrong predictions on
the same sort of rate but it was just
the fact that the HTP was running so
quick I could quickly get this into the
right position so it just allowed me
better better the better ability to demo
it in like an overfitting way yeah and
the thanks the last question story of
all that have you tried you know v3 in
terms of do you trying to improve the
inference speed I so the models I've
tried is I actually started with because
they had
a list of pre-trained models online I
started with the mobile net SSD version
2 because I thought it was better and
honestly let me let me show something so
honestly it was terrible and it didn't
work with what I needed so I had these
printed out as a backup because it just
it didn't work with the toy cars and
then someone said oh they've got two
models we got version was like one of
these version one surely two is better
no turns out version one is quite a lot
better so I haven't used any other
models than just those two models thank
you for the talk especially the demo kit
is amazing and I have like questioners
there are other solutions accelerating
infinite inferno on the Raspberry Pi
like Intel more videos for example have
you have any comparison have you have
you chosen this like intentionally or
about the other the other USB sticks
available to do this sort of thing I
haven't done the comparison myself how
are there's loads of I've seen some
medium posts or people that I've
actually done they and that's where I
got the comparison of what it looks like
compared to a desktop GPU so personally
I haven't but I have seen comparisons
online and this one seems to be sort of
pretty good yeah
what's the next steps putting on an
actual bike what's the next steps just
like a lot of glue I think I honestly
have no clue
I do want yeah I don't know are you
gonna do it if any tips yeah maybe
because I just want to get it on the
bike as soon as possible so yeah I just
spray zip tie it on how do power it oh
do I have one with me so I don't I don't
have one with me no do i oh wait there's
charger did I anyway so phone if you've
ever you have phone charging battery
packs so yeah so turns on those those
battery packs send out like a nice
stable 5 volts and most likely it burned
two amps of current which is perfect for
powering the Raspberry Pi so that's how
I powered my rugby robot two years
so I'm just going to plug it into a
phone battery bank you know it should
just work
[Applause]